[Music]
before fifty shades of gray before
easily accessible internet porn the
sexiest thing you could see in the
screen was probably not showgirls you
know it has a cult classic or does that
movie you'd watch on mute as a kid but
in 1995 showgirls was the biggest deal
in Hollywood as the first nc-17 film to
get a wide release pinned by the
highest-paid screenwriter directed by
the guy who made Basic Instinct and
hated by nearly everyone who was alive
at the time they don't do anything
original in the screenplay at all I
didn't care for the film well I didn't
either no you remember Elizabeth
Berkeley from Saved by the Bell now
she's all grown up and she's bringing
the same energy she brought to the
caffeine pills episode Water Act
balls-to-the-wall no matter what's
happening in the scene whether it's
dancing dancing even harder speaking ah
whoa sorry or just anything really
she'll chew the scenery like a rabid dog
then lick it afterwards for good measure
that could not be sanitary fun or insane
journey from the seedy strip clubs at
the bottom to the bizarre volcano
Acrobat shows at the top with only one
person crazy dancing in her way crystal
Connors she's the top girl in Vegas and
the only thing she loves more than the
spotlight his dog food I still love
doggy Chow and the only thing she loves
more than dog food is cocaine
turns on the finest cocaine in the world
and the only thing she loves more than
cocaine is the word darlin darlin darlin
darlin darlin darlin darlin darlin
you're from the valley darlin you're not
fooling anybody do you like sex well not
for long
thrill as showgirls teases you with
nudity then beat you over the head with
it until everyone has the appeal of raw
meat in this film that Rob's boobs of
all their mystery treat sex like a cheap
commodity to be bought and sold I'll
fire for you and depicts love as
something that happens between a man and
a particularly aggressive fish be
careful kids
that's not how sex works but it's
exactly how you get a yeast infection
so hike up your g-string and dance like
no one's watching you can't because this
is either one of the most campy shallow
movies ever made must be weird not
having anybody complain yet or it's a
brilliant satire of show business that
works on levels most people can't even
comprehend unlike a lot of different
champagnes but I always stick with
champagne
mmm story
Elizabeth buzzer clay patina Gershon
that 90s haircut tragic Mike Joel
Schumacher's Gotham the shape of water
and being a lady on the Internet okay
show me a strip up to the streets
[Music]
the only thing funnier than watching
showgirls watching with the isolated
audio
[Applause]
we are the as guardians of the galaxy I
am Elon Musk I am the future
my nephew wanted to be Batman so I
killed his parents
stir whip stir whip whip whip stir -
chi-ching - chi-ching - chi-ching